Let's check out
the fundamentals of Groovy so
we can better understand what's
going on in Gradle build scripts.
Before we get started looking at code,
a pet peeve of mine in online courses
is when you have to constantly
pause the video to copy down code.
You don't have to do
that in this course.
All the code we'll demo is included
in the course GitHub repository.
Groovy exists to fill a hole for
Java developers who need
a scripting language.
It's terse, expressive and
it operates extremely well with Java and
has some special features that make
it ideally suited to creating domain
specific languages.
Gradle even provides it's
own Groovy distribution so
we don't even need to install Groovy.
We can just put our Groovy code
in a build doc Gradle file and
ask Gradle to do any
task that uses the file.
To start off with, we'll declare a task
called Groovy that doesn't do anything.
We'll be talking about
this syntax in a minute.
Don't worry about it for now.
All this is doing is just telling
Gradle to go ahead and load this file.
If we go ahead and run that task by
running gradle groovy, what we see is
that Gradle runs the Groovy task but
doesn't really do anything.
That's what we expected.
All right, let's dig into Groovy, and
you know where we have to start, right?
Of course we gotta
start with hello world.
Let's try running this build
script again and see what happens.
All right, we see our message,
we've successfully reached hello world.
Let's do something more interesting.
Most Java is also valid Groovy.
Let's test that out by creating
a very simple JavaGreeter class,
just as one method to say hello.
And prints hello Java to standard out.
If we create an instance
of that class and
then tell it to say hello
let's see what happens.
Remember this is Groovy not Java.
Let's run our gradle groovy
task again and there we go.
Hello Java.
Gradle is an optionally typed language.
That means that you can give all of your
variables types if you want to, but if
you don't feel like it you can declare
variables just using the def keyword.
In this case, we're just declaring
a variable called foo with value 6.5.
We can also execute simple
groovy code inside a string,
by creating a block of curly
braces preceded by a dollar sign.
While dynamic typing is really nice,
sometimes it is good to know
the class of a variable.
We can do that simply by calling
dot class on any variable.
Finally, dynamic typing
also allows us to reassign
a variable to a different type.
This isn't very good practice but
it's good to show off.
All right, let's give this code a try,
awesome it looks like foo has value 6.5,
yep that's what we expect
down at this line.
Looks like five plus six
does indeed equal 11.
Looks like Groovy was nice
enough to do this math for us.
And then finally it looks like foo is
of class Java math big decimal when it
has a value of 6.5.
But then when we reassign
foo to a string it
looks like foo now has
the class java.lang.string.
Let's have a look at how to
declare functions in Groovy.
It looks somewhat java-like but note the
def out front instead of a return type.
Also we don't need a return statement.
The last expression in the function
block is what's returned.
So this function takes its input and
doubles it.
We can call it with a number, however,
since plus is overloaded in Groovy,
we can also call it with a string.
Let's check out the output of
these invocations of doubleIt.
All right, looks like doubleIt,
with the argument five gives us ten and
doubleIt with the argument the string
foobar, gives us foobarfoobar.
Fantastic.
There's one more super cool
feature of Groovy, and
that is whenever a function is called
with at least one argument and
it's unambiguous, you can usually
leave off the parentheses.
Let's give that a try.
I've set us up with three functions
here, one of which no args,
one with one arg, and one with two args.
Let's see what we can do.
If we go ahead and call our one arg
function with some argument and
we don't put any parentheses around it,
well, let's see what happens.
Hey, we successfully
called the function.
All right.
Now let's give the two
argument function a try.
Note, we still have to separate
the arguments with a comma.
All right, let's see how it goes.
Beautiful, no parentheses,
still getting a function call.
Let's see if we can pull the same
trick with the no argument function.
Looks like something exploded.
It turns out,
you can't use no parentheses when you're
invoking a function that
doesn't have any arguments.
Otherwise Groovy is confused
about what's going on.
All right.
Let's try something real hard now.
We're doing a nested function call.
So we've got two args.
And then the first arg,
22 args is one arg past 500.
And then 200 is going to be
the second arg, for two args.
You think this is going to work?
Let's give it a try.
Hm.
Looks like something broke.
Looks like there's something
weird going on in here.
Turns out this is actually ambiguous.
It's not clear to Groovy whether you
want to pass two arguments to one arg or
what's going on here.
Fortunately, we can make
this unambiguous with
just a couple of parentheses around 500.
Now that we've added those parentheses,
let's see if it works now.
[SOUND] Beautiful,
we're getting the nested function
call exactly how we want it.
First the one arg function is being
called then the two arg function is
being called.